madame la Première ministre un
adolescent est mort lors d'un contrôle
de police un adolescent qui n'aurait pas
dû mourir et nous disons l'immense
tristesse qui est la nôtre à la famille
de Naël et à ses proches
depuis une semaine la France a connu des
nuits de violence dans de nombreux
villes de toute taille des pillages et
destruction des agressions et ses actes
nous le disons sont intolérables nous
avons accompagné au premières heures les
appels au retour à la paix civile et au
respect de l'ordre public
nous pensons à toutes les personnes
policiers gendarmes pompiers commerçants
habitants de ces quartiers à nos mers
qui ont eu à connaître des agressions la
peur parfois la destruction souvent et
représentant de la nation nous devons
nous tenir résume en résolument aux
côtés de cela
mais nous savons qu'il n'y a pas d'ordre
sans justice voilà pourquoi devra venir
sans attendre l'heure des réponses
politiques un pays dans lequel des
milliers de jeunes personnes souvent
mineurs se lancent pendant des jours et
des nuits dans de telles équipées est un
pays qui va mal notre responsabilité
collective individuelle et de regarder
la vérité en face et d'en tirer toutes
les conséquences ghettoïsation de
certains de nos quartiers pauvreté
discriminations mal logement disparition
des services publics mis en échec de nos
institutions soit autant de difficultés
profondes dont ces fréquents
débordements de violence fait d'une
minorité sont aussi un symptôme il
faudra bien évidemment remettre sur le
métier le plan Borlo abandonné soutenir
dans la durée la politique de la ville
l'école les associations et l'éducation
populaire nous devons aux françaises et
aux Français ou qu'ils vivent la
République partout et pour tous enfin
nous devons avec sérénité et sérieux
traité de la question du rapport entre
une part de la population et la police
qui n'a cessé de se détériorer comme
nous ne pourrons pas
ignorer non plus la question de l'usage
des armes c'est à dire de l'évulation de
la loi que nous réclamons madame la
Première ministre nous ne pouvons
comprendre cette excusée ce n'est pas
excuser comprendre c'est agir dans la
justice et la paix que comptez-vous
faire madame la première la première
ministre vous avez la parole
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
Boris Vallaud
je tiens tout d'abord à vous remercier
car vous avez condamné sans ambiguïté
les violences qui ont touché de
nombreuses communes et appelées à la
paix civile à la différence de vos
alliés insoumis
et monsieur le Président vano j'entends
vos interrogations sur les racines de la
crise et les réponses que nous pouvons
apporter notamment au travers de la
politique de la ville cette réflexion de
plus long terme elle aura lieu mais je
peux vous dire que nous n'avons pas
cessé d'agir pour les quartiers et pour
la politique de la ville depuis 6 ans
depuis 2017 nous avons augmenté le
budget de l'Agence nationale pour la
rénovation urbaine portée à 12 milliards
d'euros nous avons mis en œuvre les
cités éducatives nous avons dédoublé les
classes de CP et de CE1 et déployer
100000 emplois francs au bénéfice des
habitants des quartiers alors oui nous
devons mener une réflexion s'il vous
plaît sur les causes de cette crise avec
tous les groupes politiques de l'arc
républicain dans ces moments notre
responsabilité c'est l'écoute des
propositions des élus notamment des élus
de terrain c'est aussi assumé
collectivement la complexité du sujet et
construire des réponses efficaces avec
chacun et c'est notamment le sens de
l'échange que le Président de la
République a en ce moment même avec près
de 300 mères dans les communes ont été
touchées par les violences comme nous
avons eu l'occasion d'en parler hier
monsieur le Président nous sommes encore
mobilisés et concentrés sur le retour de
l'ordre républicain et la réparation
mais je vous l'assure monsieur le
Président Vallot nous sommes déterminés
à continuer à agir pour l'égalaxer à nos
services publics et pour l'égalité des
chances surtout notre territoire je vous
remercie merci beaucoup madame la
Première ministre